Emily you we came to Pakistan because
it's a city full of culture wonderful
architecture castles and palaces and
lagos ii i'm on it's not far from Berlin
not more than an hour might seem all
there are lean meat energy gum this is
the Dutch quarter it's lovely yes and
yes it's lovely you'd almost think we're
in the Netherlands the Dutch quarter was
built in 1734 for Dutch immigrants mean
I think they ask what if you look
closely you see there's no space between
the houses una una they're connected
like links on a chain you miss Barlow
does this come on Sally it's almost like
we've left Germany for a moment the
houses usually always have a small gap
between them
mita look at the Santa Claus is made out
of chocolate a stone Papa Noel I wish
you a Merry Christmas I wish okay slaps
a little silly let's take a picture
beside one I keeping up with him this is
an advent calendar we don't have this in
Colombia it's a German tradition yes
German locus la formal my now Marlene
it's a nice German way to approach
Christmas know you got soul ozs almost
every day you get a small gift when I
late lady now we've had some first
impressions of potsdam in the Dutch
quarter so let's continue let's go to
the neue gotten or new garden let's go
on the new garden is a park in the north
of pottstown
it's cold but it's lovely bit o any
thoughts yeah it's like a two well this
is the marble palace let's take a look
the marble palace was the summer
residence of Prussian King Frederick
William the second Eunice is in misty
will this is the entry hall it's made
entirely of marble and goings incredible
I de Puebla Cooper and here's the dome
admit a little oil purpose it's all
covered in sea shells or almost as if we
were by the ocean como si tuviera que
algo con el monte alegre okay maybe it's
supposed to frighten off the nymphs now
he loves me Ian tone says a yes time and
that's also why there's the view of the
lake I mean I got a neighborhood over
there looks quite wealthy say no Donna
yes the houses are big and expensive why
not some poking through it's so hard to
believe don't they Berlin is so hectic
almost like at home in Bogota but here
yeah it's just half an hour away and so
quiet and peaceful Inc really know
and finally to top it off they take a
stroll through the Christmas market
Wow elegant look at all those hearts and
each one has a different message on it
so let's get pants I mean Germans are
pretty creative with their Christmas
trees look you even have frogs and
pickles welcome bein rip you know well
you know that I don't know what you put
on your tree but i only use regular
round ornaments
when open it was a nice day and a long
one out of weekend adventure and quite
chilly so we'll say goodbye with some
warm gluhwein we need to Caliendo with a
typical German mine no Kemal be no
nosotros salud